hammad he's a Hamas spokesman and a
former deputy foreign minister for the
government in Gaza and he joins us on
the phone uh many thanks for joining us
I want to ask you firstly what is the
objective of uh of this operation that
Hamas is engaged in this
morning you know first of all that U we
f up of the isra crimes against our
people in the West Bank in Jerusalem in
Gaza every day we are suffering from the
the brutal crimes against our people in
laka every day they are uh storing the
they preventing the the prayers from
praying in Theos every day the spend the
they entering the the Palestinian
killing people uh attacking homes they
building more settlements coning lands
uh doing all kinds of crimes against our
people and on Gaza they are continuing
in imposing The Siege and embargo and
sanctions on Gaza and we have connected
many mediators to in order to stop this
but every day we see that Israel
escalating Israel is doing uh very bad
action against our people brutal action
against our people they don't take care
about the International Community
international law they think that they
are above of law doing all of I think we
have decided to stop them all and can I
ask you about the actual operation that
you've carried out Hamas we know is not
a regular army yet it managed to prepare
and Carry Out carry out this
unprecedented full scale attack not only
from the land but also from the air and
the Sea how could that happen even as
Israel controls the whole of the Gaza
Strip Around the
Clock you know that we are we are living
under the occupation we have to prepare
ourself we have to develop our our
capability and capacity and uh I think
we every day we prepare ourselves for
for fighting against occupation and U it
is not the first time but I think this
is time is qualitative thing it is a
comprehensive it is a land from Air from
everywhere maybe is time accustom that
that there are some roets say come from
Gaza here and there so they think that
it is easy to control but I think this
is a big blow to Israel uh big blow to
their intelligence big blow to the
shabat big blow to the military
intelligence in Israel and to their army
because some people think that Israel is
a that is a strong country no one can
defeat Israel no one can stop Israel
just we send the smaller groups small
brigades Froman brigades and I think
they succeeded to do something that many
many countries they could not do that I
think this is a big listen to Israel
that they should stop crimes against our
people st stop storming Alamos stop
building settlements stop killing our
people in the West Bank because I think
they now if they now insisted to attack
Gaza to strike Gaza and to come uh
conduct crimes against our civilian in
Gaza I think they can kill people but I
think we can do something which hard
Israel hard all citizen inside Israel
and we can stop their their their
arrogance and we can D them so I think
they should understand that Hamas bades
and all Palestinian infection they can
do something kind it change the equation
in Palestinian territory can I ask we
know Israel's already launched this
operation iron sword and uh Rockets
already now firing into Gaza do you
worry about the people living there we
already know that it is ordinary people
that feel the brunt of these attacks
many of them living so closely
together look all the time we are we
were trying to avoid war and we are very
interested to protect our SE our people
in G and to to offer a good life for
them but I think uh what's happened in
the west tank what happened in Jerusalem
what happened in lamos and even what's
happening in Gaza I think no one can can
peer can tolerate more in such suffering
and pain which is every day here in the
heart of all Palestinians we know that
isra may can kill people can do it it's
not the first time it happened in 2009
2021 and even in 2023 and isra I think
is is accustomed then to to conduct a
crimes against our people but you they
have to understand that we are not
afraid we are as a Palestinians we have
determination to fight against
occupation we want to put in for dis
occupation which is the source of all
kinds of evils kinds of instability
kinds no there were I I hope that that
that some countries especially uh Arab
countries who normalize with Israel
should understand that it is a brutal
country is a brutal state which is built
on the skulls of the Palestinians on the
blood of the Palestinian bed St
normalization with is I think it is
shame for anyone who come and make
normalization of Israel so are you
saying so are you saying sir this
operation is a message to Arab countries
who have been normalizing relations with
Israel yes yes I think it is a shame for
them it is a shame and it is a big shame
and I ask all Arabic countries all
Arabic countries to disconnect and to
cut relationship with Israel because I
think it is not it is not a human it is
not it is sorry it is not a a a state
which believe in peace or or existence
or believe in in good to be a good
neighbor I I think isra is is anyy State
and we have to stop them thank you for
your time gazi hammad the spokesman of
Hamas and a former deputy foreign
minister for the government in
Gaza okay it's just gone